[Music]
what's going on guys any good movies
coming out this week uh yeah it's Star
Wars week and we are bringing you a
review now hold on we're not gonna have
any spoilers because guess what I
haven't seen the movie yet but we have
three dudes here who've seen it they're
ready to talk about it and let you know
what they thought spoiler free review
first you know him you love him he's the
movie fights champ Dan Merle and he's
the pit boss Ken app doc and you know
him you love him the host of movie
fights and he signor
so guys you all saw the movie he saw it
before most people in the free world can
I just say that was the hardest thing
for me is like having to see the movie
and then not react yeah even-steven
reaction sort of spoiled yeah I've been
seeing you around the office and you're
like emotions are spoilers and we've had
to hide in dark corners of the offices
around screen junkies here to cut it so
showy should be clear we're not spoiling
the movie though we are reacting and
emotional reveal our emotions about your
that's a spoiler to you check out now
and come back after so good to know that
is established guys is it any good did
you like it yes absolutely absolutely
emotionally satisfied Wow
anyone who doesn't like it I'm gonna go
on record as an a-hole the it just it's
so well made and fun and it's not a
perfect movie but what movies ever are
these days yeah I just want to
distinguish this cuz that's the exact
same review that and II gave Jurassic
world okay and that is a bonus exactly
gone record Dan this was better than
Jurassic thank you here's what here's
where I'll make the distinction this
movie is not empty spectacle there's
heart their soul in this movie there is
craftsmanship there is love behind it
and the thing that excites me the most
about it is the characters and I'm not
talking about the ones we know I'm
talking about the ones we that we meet
in this movie so hearing that it makes
me ask is the magic back absolutely
there's energy there's humor it adds to
the myth of Star Wars but also creates a
lot of questions and when the movie ends
like I'm dying to see eight but I'm also
so excited to go back and see this again
and again and again there's layers
there's fun stuff I think it's the
funniest Star Wars film totally it's
not like a comedy but yeah there are
moments where you laugh like it's we're
equal that's why I tie it to Empire in
the humor the humor and Empire came out
of the characters and the humor in this
for the most part comes from the
characters in the performances and it's
all organic let's talk about the new
characters I loved them all to be guys
poe dameron amazing and there's a scene
in the beginning where he confronts
someone and there's you just another
edge-of-your-seat the tension this is
Oscar Isaac yes and they break it with a
joke and it just immediately you know
what you're in for and I was just like
yes this is this is gonna be good after
Isaac did a great job and that scene
alone completely set the tone for the
movie I got what they were going for
both the serious and and the humid the
dark and the light if it worked Daisy
Ridley's character I think to stand out
yeah she's a superstar plucked from
obscurity and put into this lead role
she is amazing a revelation and a world
clamoring for strong female characters
we just got one of the best of all times
so cool to hear and my favorite part of
the well the movie really but
particularly her character is and the
thing that I've complimented the
marketing on is not giving everything
away yeah and her in particular the
journey that we take with her character
yeah is the best part of the movie and
what about John boyega any specific
thoughts about he's very funny he's very
funny brings a lot of energy you could
tell he enjoyed being there and that I
said in a very good way wasn't
distracting like oh that guy's just
happy he's in Star Wars no he brought
something to it his character was a
little different in a different
direction than I thought they were
totally yeah um but he nailed it man he
was great - there's not one character in
this movie that I was like I'm kind of
on the fence about this one I don't know
every new character they introduced in
this movie I'm like loved it as a fan
and as someone hasn't seen it yet I have
a couple things I'm curious of sure one
of the things we all love about Star
Wars are it's classic portrayals of good
and evil that good versus evil do we
have that in this yes yes but I'll tell
you what I think they play very well
with what a villain is and they add some
layers to it some people might end up
having some problems with it I think
that kind of review of that is a little
wrong I think they really did a good job
bringing a new type of villain to Star
Wars but good and evil is definitely
present what they've done I think what
this movie has introduced a great
villain at a complicated villain and one
that is going to have repercussions for
preper movies to come the kylo Ren is a
really beyond being a villain he's a
great character so remaining spoiler
three here's a question that I'm going
to tiptoe around what were you satisfied
with Luke yes
I was absolutely satisfied I think they
made a brave decision that I loved I
must say no oh okay I want to talk about
it yeah yeah yeah you know what I can go
into who I was satisfied with yes
Harrison Ford yes yeah yeah and my big
worries going into it because Indiana
Jones
he was Harrison for old man Harrison
Ford kind of kind of grumbling his way
through that part it's Han Solo he's not
forgotten how to play that part but he's
older he's older he's older Han Solo but
he's not Harrison Ford pretending to
play Han Solo yeah it's Han Solo and it
is definitely a connective thread
between new hope and force awakens it's
the same solo and the other one I was
worried about was Leia
but when Leia shows up I was
hundred-percent sold 100% on board and
they do it in such a way that you're
like alright these aren't being
shoehorned in there was no point that I
felt the nostalgia was over-the-top or
forced I I thought they were too cute by
about maybe 10 to 20 percent as far as
just like throwbacks inattentional no I
think there could have been a little bit
less of it but it wasn't it wasn't over
the top it wasn't distractingly over the
time we've really kissed this movies but
a lot and maybe well-earned but any
negatives yeah yeah here's the thing
yeah if you're building this up in your
mind to be a transcendent flawless movie
going experience and you won't accept
anything less then you are gonna be
disappointed but guess what
maybe twenty movies ever are that so yes
it has flaws but at the end you know you
just have to weigh that negative to
positive
there was nothing in this movie that
took you out of the movie yeah is it
kind of a cover song at times of some
other Star Wars stuff yeah but that's
kind of what we want out of a Star Wars
movie well and I think that it is a bit
over stuff because JJ's trying to pack
30 years into this movie yeah and so I
think that there are some things going
on whether you're like wait what's
happening you kind of wish you knew more
about that but like inside we can learn
about these in later movies yeah and I'd
like to tell you enough and then there
is some exposition points but yeah medic
lorian's no midi-chlorians
I think some of the secondary characters
got a little bit short shrift yeah again
they'll have more movies maybe to take a
better stage
there were a couple of beats that I wish
had been allowed to to linger a little
bit longer a couple of events that I
wish we could have you know kind of
settled down a little more to take in
but having said that I mean first time
in my lifetime I walked out of a movie
theater excited about Star Wars that's
so good
I can't really I can't really take the
movie based on a few minor complaints
that happened did you ever check your
clock during the movie they took away
our phone so mentally there was never a
point where it's like just get to the
next scene or I hope we get to the end
of this movie err I was along for the
ride every time and when you kind of
sense the end was coming I could have
been happy with 10 more minutes Wow
yeah I was gonna say if there was any
clock checking out my point woulda been
like is this gonna be over soon because
I don't want it to be if I had walked
out of the theater turned left in
episode 8 was playing I would have gone
right up ha ha ha ha oh man that sounds
great guys final thoughts to me it's
exceeded its awoken the Star Wars kid in
me and I am ecstatic for more this movie
had amazing expectations and pressure
it was almost immeasurable and I think
it measured up to the people who made
this movie delivered is it perfect no I
didn't need to be it was emotionally
satisfying nice when the prequels came
out every time that I would try to like
it I would think about five things that
were wrong with it in this movie every
time I remember something wrong with it
I think about five things that I loved
about it so yes is it perfect no but I
am excited
once again about Star Wars and I cannot
wait to go back to a galaxy far far away
well guys I cannot wait to travel to
that galaxy far far away how excited are
you and did you see the movie yet what
do you think let us know but leave your
spoilers somewhere else by the way on
screen junkies universe next week there
will be a full discussion including some
spoilers so tune in for that if you want
to check out that kind of action I got
to thank this panel for sharing some
wonderful news
Star Wars is good we're back baby we're
we're home we're home Dan Merle can nap
socks
Andy signor Oh to the fight yes triple
lightsaber battle will I survive thank
you for watching I'm Hal Rudnick hit me
up on Twitter bye bye
fate of the galaxy hangs in the balance
give me very serious I Luke Skywalker
I'm here to rescue you
I'm here to rescue you I'm watch I can
barely understand what